this is the first time we've seen donald
trump in public since the day that
may well come to define his presidency
eight days left in the white house
and defying those who want to hold him
personally responsible
for the violence of last week we want no
violence
never violence we want absolutely no
violence and
on the impeachment it's really a
continuation
of the greatest witch hunt in the
history of politics
it's ridiculous it's absolutely
ridiculous
this impeachment is causing tremendous
anger
and you're doing it and it's really a
terrible thing that they're doing
he says his words before the riots last
week were totally appropriate
we need no reminder the president enjoys
loud support across the country
and in texas where he came to see that
border wall he promised
last week has changed little in their
minds he said we're going to march
peacefully and make our voices be heard
i never heard in that speech say let's
go over there
and jump the the walls and let's go and
attack
so this whole notion of people thinking
and trying to find a blame
that they want to put this towards the
president i believe it's absolutely
irrelevant you don't think he incited
anything in what he said on the stage
uh i don't think so not not the true
patriots like you see here until he's no
longer the president
then we won't support him but right now
he's our president we're here to support
him he's got work to do it's just
another day at the office
there are now 400 miles of new wall on
that border
evidence of promises made promises kept
says the white house
but mexico hasn't paid the american
taxpayer has
most of the 400 miles or so of new wall
actually replaces
fence that was already here and while
joe biden has said
he'll stop building the wall when he
takes office they won't tear down
what's already been built this will
remain a lasting monument
to the presidency of donald trump on a
stretch near the town of alamo named in
honor of a revolutionary siege
he came to add his own seal of approval
before reflecting on the prospects
of his own removal from office free
speech is under assault
like never before the 25th amendment
is of zero risk to me but will come back
to haunt
joe biden and the biden administration
as the expression goes
be careful what you wish for
the impeachment hoax is a continuation
of the greatest
and most vicious witch hunt in the
history of our country
he is entering the final days of his
presidency with america as divided as
ever
and huge numbers making it clear they
still don't accept his departure
greg milam sky news alamo in texas